لقد تحدثت سابقًا مع الدكتور غسان أبو في
مدينة غزة، أخبرني عن
إطلاق نار متواصل شبه مستمر من حوله
يهتز المبنى وطابور لا نهاية له من
الجرحى الذين لا يستطيعون الحصول على العلاج الذي
يحتاجون إليه، وقد انتقل من
مستشفى شيفر إلى  مستشفى العلي
وهو المستشفى الوحيد الذي يعمل الآن
في غازي الشمالية تحدث عن
الظروف التي يعمل فيها هو وزملاؤه
استمعوا
لهذا فأنا حاليا مستشفى العلي
وهو المستشفى الوحيد الذي يعمل في غزة أه
هذا هو المستشفى الذي  تم
استهدافه بداية الحرب
وتعرض لأضرار جزئية وبالتالي لم يكن
لدينا سوى غرفتي عمليات وبعض
الأرض فقط فلور دبليو عندما
انهار مستشفى الشفاء قبل أربعة أيام أصبحنا
المستشفى الوحيد في مدينة غزة
وبدأنا في استقبال الجرحى أه من
في البداية تعرضت جميع الغارات الجوية ولكن
اليوم أيضًا إصابات قناص،
لدينا أكثر من 500 جريح في
المستشفى، لا يوجد سوى
غرفتي عمليات وثلاثة جراحين انضم إلينا
بالأمس طبيب توليد
بدأ في توليد الأطفال لأنه
لم يتبق هناك خدمة أمومة
في غزة
و  ولذا فهو يقوم ببعض عمليات الولادة وبعض عمليات
الولادة الطبيعية، ونحن
مرهقون للغاية وفي ظل الموارد المحدودة
نقوم بإجراء إجراءات مؤلمة حقًا
بدون مخدر لأننا
نحاول الحفاظ على المخدر
ولأننا لا نستطيع الوصول إليه
غرف العمليات ونحن نحاول الاحتفاظ بها
لإجراء معظم
العمليات المنقذة للحياة، مكتظة للغاية وقليلة
الموارد، وكما يمكنك أن تسمع
هناك، فإن التواصل مع الأشخاص الموجودين داخل
غزة لا يزال صعبًا للغاية،
ولم نتمكن من إجراء اتصالات على الإطلاق إذا
انضممت إلينا بالأمس واليوم  لقد
قدمنا ​​اعتذارًا مهتزًا حقًا عن
خط الهاتف هذا، لكننا اعتقدنا أنه من
المهم أن تسمع ما
يحدث داخل تلك المستشفيات في
شمال غزة، ونشكر مرة أخرى
الدكتور أبو على وقته بالطبع.